so we've learned about many of the lies  that new Republican Congressman George  Santos told about himself to get himself  elected he lied about his employment  history he lied about his educational  history he lied about being Jew he  didn't die he lied about being Jewish  but another way that he uh fleeced or  tricked or scammed donors into donating  is that a Santos campaign fundraiser  impersonated being Kevin McCarthy's  Chief of Staff just total flat out  impersonation there is no bottom that we  have at least yet found to this guy's  dishonesty and immorality and if I were  a betting man and I'm not I would bet  that there is much more to be revealed  about George Santos what do you think we  will find out next let me know in the  comments